foreign
all right so Priyanka says that she has
done two projects in bioinformatics
including Schrodinger Maestro docking
and art programming also and now she
also wants to learn about machine
machine learning that's pretty
interesting and what about the rest of
you guys I'm curious to know about
your background as well
how would you rate yourself are you a
beginner in machine learning or are you
intermediate or Advanced how would you
rate your Proficiency in the field I'm
curious to know
[Music]
or so uh let's start with today's
webinar hello everyone a very warm
greeting to one and all my name is
I would like to welcome you all for
today's webinar on machine learning for
health informatics Health informatics is
a rapidly growing field that involves
collecting and analyzing Healthcare data
and creating new job opportunities where
computers and Healthcare Providers work
together it's pretty closely related to
the field of Public Health and with the
increasing use of big data analytics in
the healthcare field the demand for
health informatics jobs are predicted to
increase over the next decade
considering the scope and degree of
complexity in health informatics we have
designed the machine learning for health
informatics program to skill up
individuals who may come from the
healthcare as well as data science do
and in today's webinar we are joined by
Dr Jeet sarkar senior balance marriage
scientist at Lowe's data will be
introducing us to the field of
healthcare informatics this will be
followed by sharing of program details
and the registration process so before
we begin with today's webinar let me
also take a brief moment to introduce
you to the team behind the program we
are a us-based bioinformatics company
who is working with multiple academic
and Commercial collaborators to develop
easy to use analytical tools and our
mission is to make bioinformatics more
accessible
and as a part of the program students
will have access to the omox logic
training that have been completed by
over 24 000 participants from 187
countries in over 300 workshops and due
to this fast growth our team is working
with local and Regional coordinators
that are helping refine local program
Logistics and adapting them to the needs
of students and researchers around the
world and this training has been
completed by participants in six
different specialization tracks that
includes oncology infectious diseases
Precision medicine Neuroscience data
science or biomedical data and
comprehensive training on oming's data
analysis
students will also have access to the
omics logic resources public logic is
important for practical and theoretical
learning of bioinformatics it takes a
combination of training modules data
analysis tools curated project data sets
and interactive sessions with mentors to
give the student a clear path of the
Bloom's taxonomy pyramid and no matter
what the user's initial experience with
bi-informatics is or mix logic is a
useful tool for gaining a baseline
knowledge of the theory behind
biasmatics analysis of large data sets
and introduction to basic coding
languages like R in python or even
beginning a data analysis project
this also comes with an access to the
omanstrology courses which includes
courses on bioinformatics Precision
medicine multi-omics that includes
genomics transcriptomics metagenomics
epigenomics data science that consists
of using R and python as well as
cheminformatics
and example projects of different fields
which you could learn from and replicate
for your research work
users will also be given directions to
access the T by info platform for
bioinformatic processing and Analysis of
data the platform includes demo
pipelines as well as data management and
Analysis Cloud infrastructure to run the
bioinformatic pipeline and different
stages of analysis are performed in
different sections on this multi-ohomics
platform
so now to view the various courses
example projects student projects you
need to first sign up on the women's
logic learn portal before that let me
walk you through a brief demo on what a
completed profile on the portal looks
like
so once you have signed up on the portal
these are the features you need to
update on your account that is the
completed profile will have a profile
image per name with appropriate
capitalization link to your social media
handles a brief bio about yourself that
will consist of your educational
background and research interest the
mentors can view your progress under the
activity tab the courses you are
currently completing will appear under
the courses tab finally after the
completion of your course the
certificates will appear under the
certificates app so with that let us
Begin by signing up on the almost logic
plan portal before proceeding with
today's webinar
I'm sharing the link in the chat box for
the participants to
sign up on the portal
so for those participants who are new to
the portal and want to create an account
you can simply click on the create an
account option that you see here and you
can enter your name email ID and
password or you also have an option to
sign up using any of your social media
handles such as Google Facebook account
Apple account GitHub account or even
Twitter and for those participants who
already have a pre-existing account on
the portal you can simply click on the
login now option that you see here and
sign in so with that I'll pause for a
couple of seconds for the participants
to sign up so that I can show you the
various courses and example projects and
student projects that are there on the
total and once you have signed up on the
portal please put a yes in the chat box
so that I can proceed
I'm monitoring the chat box for your
responses
if you're having any technical queries
or so you can read that as well in the
chat box and I'll be happy to help
all right so
Priyanka Shruti suhasi has signed up
what about the rest of you has everyone
signed up on the portal please put a yes
in the chat box
and I'll walk you through the
demonstration of how to navigate the
portal
all right I'm going to proceed along but
along the way if you're having any
queries please feel free to share it in
the chat and I'll be happy to help so
since I already have an account on the
portal I'm going to click on sign in
option so once you sign in you'll be
able to see the various courses that are
there so for those participants who do
not have a prior knowledge of my
informatics there are several
um introductory courses on
bioinformatics that you can go to or if
you have a specific interest such as
machine learning you can simply enter
the keyword that you're interested in
such as machine learning that will show
you the various courses and example
projects that makes up use of the
machine learning concept so you can
browse through and navigate at your own
pace and explore the various courses
that are there so now moving on to the
part that where you have to update your
account so that you can simply click on
the tab that says welcome back with your
email ID
so once you click on that you'll be able
to see a profile icon such as this so
once you click on this that will this
will provide you with the options to
edit your details such as uploading your
profile picture editing your bio adding
your name and as well as linking your
social media handbooks and as I
mentioned before under the activity tab
the mentor of your program as well as
the community manager will be tracking
your learning progress under the courses
tab you will be able to see the various
courses that you are currently
completing once you complete a project
and publish it on our portal you'll be
able to view it under the project stack
and once you enroll for the program such
as the machine learning for health
informatics that will appear under the
programs tab after the completion of the
associated quizzes and assignments
you'll be able to receive the
certificates under the certificates so
with that I'll pause for a couple of
seconds all right everyone has signed up
so if no one has any queries let's move
on to the next part of today's webinar
uh that is I am excited to invite Dr
Jeet sarkar he is a physician scientist
with a keen interest in data analytics
and precision medicine he's passionate
about finding meaning out of biomedical
data and leveraging them for better
clinical outcome and his work generally
involves offering meaningful and
translational guidance to biological and
Healthcare organizations currently
working as a senior bioinformatic
scientist I'm sure we'll be able to
learn a lot from him about the fields
and opportunities that are present in
the field and with that now I'd like to
pass on the stage to Dr Ajit selka or
videos
thanks
hey y'all
let me go and share my screen
is my screen visible
yes so we can see your slides
so once again thanks recovery for the
opportunity so as you know today is the
third webinar
to introduce the scope the course which
we are going to start from the 11th of
Jan
machine learning for health informatics
so in the last two webinars we had
discussed about the program overview and
also the program background now today's
topic is mainly to introduce you to the
Hands-On training
which we will be having as a part of
this particular course
so today's agenda I will be covering a
short recap of the last two webinars and
I will just introduce the case studies
which we will be covering in the coming
course
followed by a Hands-On demo for the
particular case studies
so just to recap about myself so I am
basically a
clinician turned scientist I started
with my graduation and clinical
residency
about almost
six years back and then I shifted
towards towards research more majorly
clinical research and biography research
for the last two years I have shifted to
the industry where actually I
find meaningful uh meaningful insights
from Healthcare and biotech data using
machine learning and other AI based
tools
so how
data science is transforming Healthcare
in today's
scenario so as I already covered in the
first webinar so there are three major
sections where Healthcare in data
science actually makes sense the first
and the most important is patient care
so now how do we patient care so how do
we provide patient care patients are
actually
sort of a
concentration of multiple types of data
so we can use that data historical data
for patient care prediction for risk
stratification
for precise Diagnostics to detect a
disease very early in the disease course
to do patient triage and also for some
Imaging and diagnostic purposes so this
five are mentioned are actually some of
the use cases which we are
which we generally use for patient care
the next part is what you can see is
business process and management so
Healthcare domain contains lots of
business processes and management
starting from hospital bed occupancy
estimation to appointment management to
claims Administration
to business insights so these things
also we can solve using Healthcare data
and by applying data science and ml
models on Healthcare data last and
actually the majorly studied academic
area is biotech and pharmaceuticals so
actually we can use Healthcare data we
can use clinical trial data for drug
Discovery for improving clinical trials
to make them much more faster and
sweeter and also to plan Logistics so
there are multiple areas where data
science is going to transform Healthcare
so these three are just a glimpse or a
bird's eye view of some of the use cases
now what Solutions can we can we
conceive in the domain of healthcare
informatics
so here I have mentioned six big classes
so we can do prediction so we can
predict if a patient is going to have a
incident of fall or incident of stroke
or incident of
hypoglycemia in the coming one hour one
week or one month we can cluster
different patients as per their
pathology and provide a much more
precise therapy for a particular patient
using remote patient monitoring devices
like fitbits and variables we can
continuously stream the real-time data
coming from our patient's Fitbit or
Apple watch and from there we can
predict
uh heart attack or sort of a reduced
oxygen saturation before the event
actually occurs
so image analysis we can classify extra
images CT scan images we can even
classify video image video images using
machine learning algorithms another
thing is 100 text analysis so actually
clinical nodes contain very rich
semantic information clinical roots are
written by physicians nurses and
administration administrators so we can
apply natural language processing sort
of thing to extract insights from
Clinical nodes and we can merge multiple
types of models to build a custom model
for a specific use case purpose
to specify so as I told that there is
something called Precision therapy so
there may be a group of patients suppose
hypertensive patients patients who are
suffering from hypertension partitions
were suffering from diabetes or patients
who are suffering from a particular
breast cancer now that can be different
subtypes of that particular disease so
breast cancer may have different
subtypes as per the genetic mutation or
the genetic modification and those
precise clusters will be responding to
very precise drug regimes so identifying
that precise cluster followed by
Administration about precise drug regime
is what we call as Precision therapy in
oncology so this is one use case for
health informatics we can detect and
classify tumors so tumors from CT scan
images from MRI images we can detect
small tumors we can detect skin lesion
skin tumors and classify them as per
their severity
also in the context of mental health we
can take multiple social network
posts
yes Charles so are we going to take
questions now or at the end of the end
of the webinar
yeah it looks like he is unable to
unmute himself um I'll ask him to share
his query in the chat and we can proceed
with the presentation sure sure
and lastly for mental health we can use
social network posts we can do sentiment
analysis to detect the level of
depletion to detect anxiety from those
Network ports so we can use almost each
and every type of data
use a plethora of models to provide
Healthcare Solutions
and to for the next slide I present here
the different types of healthcare data
so this can be electronic medical
medical records which contains very rich
patient physician and nurse interaction
and all the notes in a very unstructured
way we have medical images we have
slides which is really slides we may
have weak big volume multi-oh mixed data
from especially for oncology patients we
can have abdomological data
we can have time series data we can have
clinical notes and social network data
so all these data types can be used in
one or another way to using via models
we can generate insights to provide much
more precise and Coordinated Care
so
for to for this program uh in the
Hands-On program we will be discussing a
brief introduction about the overview
background and Healthcare types followed
by some case studies Hands-On case
studies and this is how the case study
structure would look like so first we
would introduce you to the case study
what's the background and the objects of
the case study then we will introduce
the overview of data so how does the
data look whether it's continuous
categorical mix of continuous and
categorical
the target variable the predicted
variable and then we will do some data
exploration where we will see the
distribution of data the type of data if
we need to change some data type
then we will do some model building
where we will select the predictors
Target and the model which we will be
building
lastly after we have done build the
model we will do something called Model
validation where we will
measure the accuracy sensitivity
specificity of the model so there's
something called true positive rate
then through negative rate false
positive rate Fox negative rate so those
things we will discuss and lastly we
will also end with model interpretation
something which is very important in
healthcare informatics where we will
explain why and how the model predicted
a particular outcome in for a particular
patients
so as I told we will be dealing with two
case studies
one case study is majorly using
supervised learning the other is majorly
exploding unsupervised clustering and
the context is heart disease so as you
know or you so just to mention so almost
the leading cause of mortality is
cardiovascular event so cardiovascular
event means hurting so it's the biggest
killer for both the Sexes globally
whatever disease you may be having
suppose you suffer from diabetes a
person suffers from hypertension or a
different disease all of these all the
majority of the people eventually die
with a heart disease with a heart
condition
and we also have some statistical and
well reported literature which has
identified many risk factors which
associate with heart disease
for these in our course we will be using
the Cleveland heart disease data so it's
a very well curated and well structured
data set it's
um it's very widely cited and used for
multiple data science purposes we will
do some
feature exploration
of the data then we will do some
featured engineering and then we will do
some machine learning modeling
so this is just a glimpse of the data I
will be I will also cover the much more
specific
thing in the Hands-On demo today
so now let's go to the Hands-On demo
part so any questions so far or I will
just take a pause here
we had a query from kruti Rao how could
we connect ml or NLP to treat diseases
like so yes
oh
okay
so there are two questions kriti and
Priyanka so I guess they should be ml
or NLP to treat diseases like psoriasis
okay so uh
now uh now first thing uh kriti and
Priyanka so it would be a bit more
advanced
answer to your question
now
generally so in the context of psoriasis
um that there are some uh that there's a
pretty much uh evolving literature which
tells that all the auto so these ottoman
diseases so these are majorly autoimmune
diseases so what's an Autumn disease so
there are some cells called t cells in
our body
and the balance of immunosuppressive T
cells and the immunode and the
pro-inflammatory and anti
anti-inflammatory T cells is very finely
maintained in our body only when this
balance is not maintained then and there
are certain T cells which starts to act
against our own body so it detects so in
the normal case the antigen which our
body has this shouldn't be detected as a
foreign antigen but in the context of
autoimmune disease these antigens the
body antigens are just called antigens
so this is the condition when the T
cells start to to inflame the body some
particular tissues which can result in
different autoimmune diseases
now for psoriasis if you tell there are
there is a some leading information
right now which tells that this is not a
very homogeneous disease so some person
may have a particular geltic genetic
signature for psoriasis some person are
defined as a signature accordingly we
should be able to Cluster these patients
from genomic data and those genomic data
we can identify the genetic signatures
which are very specific to a particular
patient and from there we can devise
much more precise
precise therapy or a precise drug regime
for a particular patient so this is a
very comprehensive thing and maybe ml
would be ml would be would fit into one
part of multi-ohmics clustering in this
context
for NLP again you are telling an episode
NLP and ml is not super valuable so NLP
is actually a part of ml so ml is a very
big genre and NLP mostly covers natural
longest language processing so it
majorly tells with clinical notes so you
can extract so so what you can do so
that there might be a you might be
having a record of patients of psoriatic
patients you might be having their
clinical history you might be having
their lab information and you can
extract the clinical history and maybe
you can find out that different cluster
of psoriatic patients present with
different clinical
clinical symptoms there you can also use
NLP so you can combine NLP with
biochemical data with multi-ohmics to
build a model and this we name as
multi-modal modeling so where we can
combine multiple types of data using
multiple different algorithms and come
out with a solution
I hope I could answer your question
so
then so rif so can you please tell me
what do you mean by arrive Priyanka
Priyanka you asked recurrent
implantation failure okay so uh so in in
the same case so implementation failure
I guess you are
so implantation means are you
implementation means are you telling
about Orthopedic implantation or some
transplantation
so whatever whatever music is so in in
the same case international failure is
is a is again and immune and immune
failure sort of thing so the body's uh
the body's implantation mechanism may be
uh hampered this may also uh fall in the
context of pregnancy also and so in that
case they are again can maybe a
particular genetic signature
which is driving the failure and if we
can detect that genetic signature via
some transcriptomic mechanism and that
we can solve using ml or ml mechanisms
I guess I could answer your question
prank
and next Krishna Kumar has asked is it
possible to use ml in Chikungunya
anti-sports complications
so of course so so actually uh there is
uh there is one word that there's one
statement that you can you can model
anything on Earth okay so uh you can
model anything but what you need is a
good data and a good model to capture
your data so of course you can also uh
model Chikungunya and its post
complications but you have to you you
have to uh generate the question
specifically you have to generate the
object specifically and you have to join
the data and clean the data structure it
much more
precisely and then you can also do the
a modeling predicting frequency
complications yes this also can be done
this is actually done because pregnancy
comes with multiple known complications
starting from
hypertension Pi PIH then anemia uh and
hypothyroid and metabolic diseases
majorly gdm gestational diabetes
mellitus
and there is actually one one very well
sorted cohort which studies the risk of
gdm among among pregnant females so you
can take a group of
females who had a history of
pregnancy complications during pregnancy
and you can take their prospective data
their age then their height weight BMI
and blood parameters then you can model
and see that then bring up and then
Define a model on this model you can use
for a new patient to tell that this
question is having a risk of diabetes or
PIH or anemia like that so you can also
do that
okay so to build a good model how much
number of training data is expected it
totally depends on the question on the
question and
thank you
on the question and also there's
something called
internal and external validation so
generally for a robust model what we do
is we build the model
so for a robust look for any robust
scientific answer we do something called
meta-analysis so what it does it it
combines multiple studies done across
multiple locations multiple Labs across
multiple times and combines all these
data to get a particular information
for ML models to build ml models we do
something called and we have something
called Discovery and validation so
suppose I take one particular data set I
will
divide it into two sets training and
test set I will build the model in the
training training set and I will test it
and I will achieve a model accuracy then
I will I will just apply the same model
into a independent population which is
called the validation data set and see
if the accuracy is coming close to it or
not so the more the data the more
accurate it becomes otherwise because
Healthcare is a very genetic
genetically driven domain so models
which work for Indian population may not
work for the U.S population which works
for the European population may not
operate for the optical population so
that that can be different other
populations and so it's best if we can
build models and apply models to that
particular population
instead of jumping or training one model
over population a and testing on
population B so it's a very it's a very
um population specific approach which we
should take
I hope you got your answer
okay so if there are no questions then
we will go to the next section so this
is the Hands-On demo which I will work
through
so can you see my Google collab
tab yes yes it is visible
okay
so
for those who are not aware of Google
collab I will just tell that so it's an
environment which provided by Google so
you can run a Jupiter notebooks here and
you can run python as well as r
now of course you can run batch in these
code chunks so you will see that there
are two particular code things called
code and text so you can write text
insert images you can also write codes
and run the codes as as some code
Snippets
so as you can see I have in the table of
contents here so this is sort of the
first case study which we will be
covering which we which I have named
supervised learning Health heart disease
risk prediction so we will use the
Cleveland Clinic heart disease data set
and we will be doing some supervised
learning models using that data set
so here you can see there are I have
divided into uh seven sections so we
will start with the introduction
and so where we will discuss heart
disease and the potential risk factors
then we will go to the data import where
we will import the data
we will convert different data types
into different data types as per our
question
we will do a very
high level Eda
EDM means exploited data analysis it's
the most important part of healthcare
modeling or any modeling which you will
do in your entire life so never skip the
step of EDM and from the EDF we will
identify important clinical variables
then I have called something as
graphical edl so this idea is more of a
well we see the summary and while we see
the data type and all those things
and then we will just graphically
represent those Eda using box plot and
histogram and pair plots different
things we will explore then we will go
to the model building where we will put
some selected variables which we get
from the EDM to build a model
and then we will extract useful
information from the model and then we
we will we will explain the model we
will measure the
importance of one variable over the
outcome
then we will do something called Model
diagnostic where we will assess the
model performance by by performance I
mean accuracy sensitivity and
specificity
then we will go to the last part but the
most important part called the model
explainability where we will do the
model interpretation
so let's so here this is the table of
contents so here there's something
called
a folder so we can add data either
through some W gate so we can add data
directly to this particular script using
the batch bash or also the python are
code code Snippets for this use case I
have the data saved in my particular
system I can also connect my Google
Drive if I if I want there's some option
called Mount right but just just to tell
you if we are doing the particular
modeling using R in that case the Mount
Drive function doesn't work only if we
are using python then we then we can
mount the trend in this case I can
upload the data from my system
so I am uploading the data from my
system
so now you can see that that data has
come here okay
so I can click on this to just see how
does it look huh
but uh I won't be doing that I will just
importing it straight into my
notebook so now let's come to the
notebook again
so it contains of these seven parts
this particular slide tells you it tells
you so this I have shown before also so
it's generally the structure of how do
how we build a supervised model from
Healthcare data so we can have different
data sources we can do the data
preparation then we can just identify
the features using Eda then we can do
the feature engineering so we can
transpose or translate or convert the
features normalize them and then we
divide it into two parts training and
validation the training set will be used
to build the model and we will do the
validation and we will try to adjust the
training and validation
and once it's done we will um did we
will arrive to a particular model and
this model we can customize by adjusting
sensitivity and specificity this is a
very important step I will tell you and
in the in the course because in
healthcare data we uh uh
on on many occasions we try to uh to
reduce the false negative cases so false
negative cases
and true and false positive cases
there's a balance if the false positive
cases if the percent of fault false
positive cases reduces then the percent
of false negative cases increases and
the vice versa
but in the in healthcare data we always
try to minimize the false
negative cases
we don't we generally we are not
concerned about the false positive cases
because we don't want any patient who
has the disease to escape the model
to get reported as non-dazings so this
is very important in the healthcare data
and then once the model is built we can
customize it then as we get new data we
that passes to the model and that gives
you a prediction and we can also explain
why the model gave this prediction for
this particular patient
so this is the pipeline or the workflow
now let's uh so as I have told this is
sort of our introduction and this is a
code snippet so I have installed this I
have upped the data here so you can see
you can if you can click on these three
dots you will see something called copy
path so you can copy this path and you
can just copy it here okay
and
so this is the first function called
read dot table so here we are just
reading it so it's a DOT CSV so it means
it's a comma separated file so the
separate is comma and header equal to
True means we are telling that in the
first line of this in the first line of
this particular file you can find the
header okay so this is the header and
these are the information
so
we can run these
cell and you have seen the head HD heart
disease data so it will print out the
first six rows of the data set
so now you can see so there are six now
this is the first six rows so the and it
contains 14 columns so the data set
contains 14 columns and if you see there
are the data types also it's a integer
integer integer integer and these are
double so it's not an it's a number
pneumatic and these are all integers so
we will explain so now the age we can so
it's the age of the patient 6 is the sex
of the patient but what is CP what is T
rest BPS what is chol what is ABS so
this needs some explanation
now again as I told for the data there
is one interesting story actually
that there was one particular New
Journey in a company who was trying to
increase the model accuracy so the
person was trying to increase the model
the data training amount the training
data he was trying to put more data he
was trying to fit a deep learning model
then uh random forest model then so
different models but anyway that person
couldn't achieve a very high accuracy
then that person came to a senior uh
from the same company and the senior
person told him that uh
focus more on feature engineering to
select the features which may be
important
and so then what the person tells in the
next part of the story that when I did
the feature engineering and after data
exploration I could reduce the number of
features but I could achieve a very high
accuracy
so uh what I mean to tell is that to
build a very robust and very good model
don't focus on the training data but
focus on the feature and this is where
the domain knowledge or the
understanding of the data comes in so if
you try to predict something by using a
feature which has no role in the
prediction then the model would be
actually underperforming you always have
to find out the the domain knowledge
does this particular predictor make
sense in the prediction only when you
are able to find out the importance
features then only you will be having a
very good model otherwise if you even if
you increase the data if you try
different models you won't succeed
so that brings us to the next chunk
which is the understanding of the data
so here you can see I have given the
name type and description so here I
explain the data and from there you can
also you can also think and you can also
do some Googling or some research to
find out that Which models are important
suppose age so here we are predicting
heart disease from age six chest pain
resting blood pressure serum cholesterol
fasting fasting blood sugar excise
induced angina and henceforth so for
heart disease age is definitely a very
important predictor the more is it the
person the risk of heart disease is
more
sex is also a very important
risk for heart disease now chest pain
yes chest pain chest pain is absolutely
a very very important predictor for
heart disease so actually because we are
working with a clean data set where you
will be seeing only those predictors
which are actually important but in the
real life scenario you will be getting a
very messy data set with lots of
variables some make sense and doesn't
make sense and from there you have to
clean the data set to find out those
variables which actually make sense in
the model and from those predictors only
you will try to build the model
okay so after that we will just discuss
in detail about all these particular
parameters why do they make sense and
like that
then there is something called Data
exploration
so here you can see that it comes with
the class so class is actually what we
will be predicting so this is the
outcome so from the all the all these
features H6 chest pain then resting
blood pressure serum cholesterol fasting
blood sugar and excise induced angina
maximum heart rate we will be predicting
if the patient is having a heart disease
so for this data set there are four five
classes zero means no presence one means
least likely to have heart disease 2 is
more than one so there is a higher
chance of having heart disease
she is there is a more higher chance
than having heart disease from two and
four is the
that is more likely has heart disease so
for the sake to make the model very uh
simple
we are we are we we can Club as no
presence and presence so you can Club
all the one to four to a single
parameter and zero into a
that's very important so for that we can
use a simple statement it's it's a if
else
code so if the class is greater than 0
then put all of them as one or else keep
it 0. so here you can see class is 0 2 1
like that so two and one both these
things will be 1 and 0 0 both into the
things will remain zero so zero means no
disease and one means has disease and we
are clubbing all of them together
so here for this particular so here you
so we are creating a new variable in
addition to the
14 variables okay so and these new
variables we are naming as
we are naming as uh
um HD or a heart disease okay so here
for this purpose we are assigned we are
passing this particular data frame or
this is underscore data so actually it
is a data frame and I guess all of you
have at least some knowledge
con of R if not then I would suggest you
to go through a very indirectly our
course just having a knowledge of some
basic packages are deployer kdr and
ggplot that that would be enough so here
you can see this is a data frame object
so all tweets variables as objects so it
stores variables as objects and here so
this is the object and
the con names we can print as call names
data and these are the call names okay
so we will be creating a new column name
called called
HD and for this we will use the function
called mutate so muted actually appends
a new column using this logic okay and
this muted for to run this muted we have
to install a package called tidy words
okay it's a very versatile package
containing multiple packages so I I have
the code I'll just run it
so now if suppose I run this you will
see there is a additional ah column
called HD okay and you can also
we can also see this particular
let's print out the first six rows and
you see that is a new door so here you
see 0 is 0 but 2 1 have been one and one
so we are reclubbing this okay
now suppose I want to see that what are
the number of patients in these two
groups okay so I can print so now you
see this is a double okay so if I uh
print the summary
it will give me a mean first quintile
median mean third quintal and Max so
because it's a integer HD is an integer
it gives my scription summary of integer
so I have to convert them into Factor
okay so this icon convert using a factor
and now you can see I have 164 cases
of no heart disease and 139 of heart
disease
now actually for this data set clubbing
them into these two particular
groups as 0 and 1 makes more sense y
makes more sense suppose I didn't Club
them so if I hadn't clubbed them so it
would be
class is what I guess
so there are 164 has 0 1 55 then so it's
decreasing and fourth so when I do the
model there are much more samples having
no heart disease and there is very low
sample having the highest category of
severe heart disease
so this is something called Data
imbalance so we are having imbalanced
data
so why is this a very tough thing
because if we are having data imbalance
then when we build the machine learning
model so a machine learning model learns
from the data now because we have much
more samples in the no heart disease
category it will learn more from this
particular category
and it will learn less from the severe
heart disease category and that will
leads to a very unfair model performance
in the this particular class the fourth
class so there is something called uh uh
recall and precision so and there's
something called a cross a matrix so
when we draw The Matrix we will be
finding that maybe a very few patients
in the fourth group would be accurately
predicted because the because the model
had seen very less data only 13 percent
so it would be predict it would be uh
performing very low in this particular
category okay so for this particular
reason we are clubbing it now it's
actually more of a balanced balanced
data set so we have 164 139 so it will
be performing
uh good in both the classes okay so
these are some some things or some uh
some sort of
a techniques which we actually use in
real case real life scenario we could
have also clubbed it into 0 1 and 2
where we put suppose the 0 as 0 1 and as
one and two three four week Club into
the soy Club X
um
no heart disease mild heart disease or
heart disease like that so that also
makes the a very balanced uh not this
this much balance Bachelor balanced and
data set
for the next part we will be going is
through the exploited data analysis so
as I told we will be exploring the data
so
Eda mainly contains of some also
contents of some statistical tests so
there are some tests called t-tests and
chi-square tests and wilcoxin tests
different tests are using for different
types of variable
so suppose in this case I had I am just
implementing a chi-square test so I will
actually compare so 6 is the predictor
and HD is the hard zero or one okay
so I can also just let me
I can just
just show you how it looks
table
so this shows you so 0 and 1 I guess 0
is
0 is female and one is male and we can
see from the data dictionary and so
this this 0 is this is 6 and this is uh
let me print it
okay so 0 is 6 and so female there are
72 females with hard with no heart
disease 25 patients with some heart
disease 92 patients with an antidote
male patients with no heart disease 114
with some heart disease so from the from
the from these
exploration simple exploration you can
see that 72 females are having heart
disease and 25
72 no heart disease 25 heart disease on
the other hand 92 males no heart disease
but 114 heart disease
so this from here I can infer that sex
is actually a predictor of heart disease
so if somebody so males have more
chances of having a disease compared to
females I can I can inference this
particular statement if I consider that
the data collection and all these things
have been randomly done there is no bias
if I consider that thing so considering
that the data collection procedure has
been random has been done using random
sampling or following proper data
collection procedures I can tell that
males have a higher disk now now so this
is I can tell from a from just a glimpse
or just an overview but if I want to
statistically confirm it I can use
something called chi-square test so this
Chi Square test is a the function is
test DOT test I will pass this to write
this two particular vectors so what does
Vector mean so h d underscore data is a
data frame and dollar six is actually a
column so one column if I uh different
if I cut from a particular it's a vector
so it will give two vectors and this
Vector gives me something called saving
as hd6 and I printing it so it tells me
that Pearson's chi-square test with yes
quantity collection
the data is like that the x squared is
this the DF is one so DF is the number
of
[Music]
uh after a degree of freedom and the P
value is less than 0.05 it's actually
much less than 0.05 so this tells me
that sex is a very important predictor
and 6 actually has an influence in
predicting heart disease
so this is for the
categorical uh variable 6 and
heart disease but if I had H so age is
not a category age is a continuous
variable in that case in this case I
would have used something called T Test
okay so before I
before I go to the
so I can I can just explore each
and you can I can just draw histogram
and you see this tells me the the
histogram it gives me the distribution
of the patients and actually it's a very
uh good and very uh it's a normal
distribution again there's something
which we visualize
something we can test using the
statistical test so I can from my visual
visual inspection I tell that this
normal distribution again for testing
normality we have Shapiro will test we
can do a QQ quantile quantile
distribution there are lots of things
which we which we will also discuss in
the there are lots of techniques so we
can we can see and we can infer we can
do the statistical text and we can infer
so there are two approaches and both
should be done to confirm the the result
okay
so for this actually we use something
called P test so it's so just we can
write T Test here and here would be h
and I haven't changed it so I will just
change it as h
and
so it gives me a wedge to sample t-test
and you can see that the uh
that the mean of X is 54 so the mean and
the mean of Y is sort of
uh
so 52 is 52 and 55 and here also
okay and this P value also tells that
it's a it's a very uh significant
variable so that means that with age the
chances of developing heart disease is
also increased so age is also a
significant predictor again in this
particular data set we have already
cleaned the data set and taken those
particular predictors which are actually
important so if we do the individual
exploration we will get all the
variables to be important but in real
life data we should be doing all of all
these things to select the important
predictors okay so this is for the Eda
now graphical Eda so this is also
graphical because we are doing some
graphs out of this and but again we can
suppose
uh now now zero and one zero so we are
again re relabeling just for the sake of
good understanding suppose here we can
decode the and we can plot the age now
you can see that for the disease
the median age is much higher but the no
disease the median age is much lower
okay so almost uh the median age in case
of no disease is close to the
first quantile of the disease so it's
definitely significant and the t-test
also tells us it's significant so we can
do some graphical exploration so in this
case we are doing a box plot because we
have two categories one is categorical
disease no disease one is continuous if
we had two continuous we would have been
done a peer plant if we have both
categories then in that case we have
done a heat map or a with a chi-square
test so we will be exploring all the
variables and I will also explain the
pause and we will also refer to some
standard literature which tells and
which actually confirms our finding
so it's sort of a literature as well as
data so it's not that data is the goal
standard we also have to consult the
literature we also have to consult the
domain experts and only then can we be
sure of our results
and then we can we will take the
important variables to build the model
so we have different models in this case
we will start with a very very easy and
the most uh widely used model uh
generalized linear model uh logarithmic
model and we will build the model then
we will extract the summary we will
accept the useful information
then predicted probability I will
explain why probability what is
probability so the intent is to tell
that if you are having one year more of
age then what is the how much by how
much percent you have a higher risk of
developing heart disease so if you are a
female and if so if you are a male then
compared to a female person what is how
much is the increase of your heart
disease risk so we also have to quantify
this particular risk so this
quantification we can do using some
classical models which are called
generalized linear models and there is
also something you might be hearing that
there's something called a black box
machine learning there's something
called interpretable machine learning
and there's something in in the between
so glm these models and uh there's
something called um tree based models
this this help us to interpret the model
but uh this can't handle complex data on
the other hand deep learning models and
random Forest models and extreme
gradient boosting models they are Black
Box models but they they have some
limitation in interpretation okay but
nowadays people are also coming with new
techniques to interpret even the Black
Box models so we will build the model
we will explain the model we will
quantify that if you are a male compared
to and so then compared to a female what
is the higher risk of your getting heart
disease if you are 40 years then
compared to a person of 30 years how
much is your risk more than to develop
heart disease
and lastly we will do the model
diagnostic so we will uh so we have
suppose 100 samples then we will run the
model over all the samples then we will
find that how many the model has
predicted right how many wrong and there
are certain metrics called area under
the car of then sensitivity then
specificity uh recall Precision you
would we will discuss and classification
error we will discuss all these things
and lastly we will go through some
things called Model explainability so
model explainability actually tells you
so if you give a new sample to the model
it will give you a prediction that this
person is having a risk of 60 percent of
developing heart rate hard disease risk
but why did it tell sixty percent so the
model so the modern explanability
algorithms will also tell you that this
person is going to Ria going is having a
risk 60 percent of developing heart
disease because us this person is a male
this person is a smoker the mean
cholesterol of this person is
above average and this person is
complaining is having a dyspnea or
distress on exertion so this will also
tell you the causes and this causes
actually helps the Physicians and the
nurses to take decisions because now
they also know that why the model has
predicted this particular thing for this
particular patient it gives more more
confidence it helps a more model
acceptance and adoption so it's a very
important topic in today's time and we
will also explain model explainability
as the last section
so I guess I will stop here today for
the Hands-On demo and uh I can take
questions if there are any
thank you so much sir uh we do have a
query from moku bhandari he's asking do
you have this notebook we can use side
by side and do we also customize the
overfitting
yes so uh so figure I guess we we will
also be uh will they also be doing this
doing this side by side doing the
Hands-On demo or it will be a sort of a
homework or a sort of assignment
or later
um and he is also asking do we also
customize the overfitting
so uh so overfitting so customizing over
fitting is actually customizing the
true positive uh false positive and
false negative in in terms of healthcare
informatics so overheating means when
the
um so overpaying means when the model is
performing very well in the training
data and very not performing in the test
data so we will also customize
overfitting so it this will fall under
the model uh model performance
evaluation and from there we will again
go to the model building
you just
thank you sir and
um do they have any further queries
I'll pause for a couple of seconds
all right so it looks like we have no
more uh queries so thank you so much sir
for joining today's webinar and taking
up the participants queries I'm sure
that the participants were able to learn
a lot about the field and from your
exiting presentation we look forward to
learn more from you during the course of
the machine learning program and with
that now I'd like to invite my colleague
from the marketing team who sharing more
about the program registration so over
to you show them
yeah um thank you sugary
so hello everyone myself shubham I am
the uh just a second first question let
me share my screen
[Music]
yeah can you confirm is my screen
visible
yes we can see our screen
okay so hello everyone uh myself shubham
I am the marketing and Business
Development here at Pine biotech I'll be
quickly briefing you about the
registration part for machine learning
for health informatics case based
learning program by Dr Jeet sarkar so as
you can see uh this is our uh the like
program page so let me share the link of
this program page first
to
you
so uh you can go through this link after
the session
so like the like this is a program page
machine learning for health informatics
case with learning and it will commence
from 11 Jan so very few days are left
for the enrollment so I would request
you to please hurry up and draw for this
program
as you will scroll down you will see the
program overview of this program so in
this uh you you will get to know about
the topics and the concepts which will
be covered or after the program what you
will be learning uh from this program so
it includes like case-based learning for
the data science and machine learning as
well as the mental guidance from
then the Big Mac to advanced level of
all the topics like data acquisition
data structuring workflow selection and
cross validation for healthcare and
clinical data analysis you will also get
to know about the analysis of data types
and various opportunities for
participants in various fields of jobs
or internships or if anyone wants to
gain experience also along with that we
will provide you the career guidance and
the certification after the program
So Below I as well scroll down you will
see an interactive calendar in which uh
you will see few dates are highlighted
so on that particular dates we will be
having a live sessions and on the right
hand side of that calendar you will see
the topics which will be covering uh
which will be covered in that particular
session so like uh you can see here like
the heart disease and risk factor as
today Dr Jean sarkar has said in told
about the using the Google collab along
with nine on in the next session we will
be covering the data and Analysis path
and some of the example overviews
so further uh down the page uh you will
get to see that we have three different
tenures for this program one is 45 days
60 days and 90 days
so you might be uh thinking about the
differences for these three different
tenures so first of all
um let me tell you the common resources
which are there for these 10 years so
the common resources are like you will
be getting the online tutorial then
project examples from our omnix logic
loan platform you will also get the
coding sessions Hands-On coding sessions
and by chance if you miss any session or
like the lecture then we will provide
you this session recording as well along
with that you will get the online mental
support and the Online technical support
from our team and after the completion
of this program you will definitely get
a certificate of completion now the
difference between these three tenures
are like for 60 days you will get 10 uh
opportunity for one-on-one Mentor
session along with that uh while going
through the courses if you uh pop up
with any of your research item then you
can propose your research proposal a
research question and even though you
can uh like present a research poster
presentation on various International
symposiums
and in the 90 days tenure you will get a
golden opportunity along with the one
advantage session and uh like along with
my mentor session you can complete your
independent research project work and
get it in the uh like published in the
peer review journal so these are the
difference between the 45 days 60 days
and 90 day standard now coming to the uh
pricing part so as you can see uh like
for in USD we have the pricings are a
dollar 150 dollar 300 and dollar 450. if
anyone like uh you can see a drop down
option here on the top right corner
where you can select the currency based
on your location
so I as I mean we are in India so like
uh for Indian uh participants the
pricing is
for 90 days So currently we are
providing the scholarship of 50 for all
three different Daniels so I will be
sharing with the steps uh to enroll
along with the coupon code the coupon
code is health50
so let's say if uh I want to enroll for
the 90 days program then you simply have
to click on buy now button
and you can type here the coupon code
which is
l50 and everything is in caps and after
that uh just click on apply
so you can see coupon is applied
successfully and you have you will see
the reduced price of 50 like that is um
7500 or 749 and after that you just fill
your details and select the payment
method
so yeah so this is the registration part
uh if you have any query uh regarding
the registration part please feel free
to message uh to type in the chat box
but by the time I will be sharing with
the steps to enroll
yeah thank you srigori for sharing the
uh details
thank you so much and if participants
have any queries uh yes we do have
couple of queries and Mukesh is asking
where will we get the coupon code
yeah I am providing you the coupon code
the coupon
code is Health 50
.
thank you so much again and uh
yesterday
so I think chirag is asking I have paid
for the course what next should I do so
chirag uh a team uh team will message
you about these sessions or when we will
be conducting the live sessions you will
get 10 calendar invitation on that
particular time you can join uh for the
live session
foreign
[Music]
so if you want to enroll for this
particular one then
um
you can mail uh you like you can uh
enter a mail ID then we will share you
the details on how to enter for this
particular program
foreign
does anyone have any further queries
I'm sharing the email ID of our
marketing manager so that uh along the
way if you're having any queries you can
mail as well can you just asking what is
the last day to enroll for the program
so the last day to enroll for this
program as you like it is and all
starting from 11th so on 15th the coupon
code will expire so I would request to
enroll before 15th to Avail the offer of
50 percent
foreign
s are having no further queries we will
be ending today's webinar
all right and thank you so much everyone
for joining today's webinar and we look
forward to seeing you at the program as
well have a great day thank you everyone